welcome back so we've been talking about
machine learning and the various
categorizations of algorithms based on
whether or not you have supervised or
unsupervised labeled data or unlabeled
data and so I wanted to walk through
kind of a flow chart to explain kind of
the decision space and what some of the
algorithms are okay so let's say you
have some system that's generating data
this is the system you're trying to
model or understand it's generating
training data that you're going to use
to build a machine learning model now
the first decision we have to make or
assess is whether or not this data is
labeled or has these kind of truth
labels did some expert label the data
with the outcomes that you want to build
the model on it so in that example of
pictures of cats and dogs do those
images have labels of which ones are
actually cats and which ones are dogs if
the answer is yes then this is a family
of algorithms called supervised learning
algorithms a huge branch of machine
learning if not then you're going to use
an unsupervised learning algorithm and
then you have to ask is your data
discrete or continuous or are the
outcomes or the things are the labels
discrete or continuous
so in the case of discrete dogs and cats
are two distinct categories that's
discrete labels
whereas continuous labels would be
something like you know a scalar
measurement of the force on a wing or
something like that so a continuous
variable maybe it's you know earning
earning potential given some some input
factors so something that is a
continuous variable versus something
discrete and if you have a supervised
learning algorithm based on discrete
labels then this is called
classification and there's lots of
algorithms including support vector
machines neural networks decision trees
random forests things like that if you
have this continuous data then you're
going to build a regression model and
these are the the kind of models we're
very familiar with in linear regression
Gaussian processes logistic regression
things like that similarly in the
unsupervised branch
depending on if my data is discrete or
continuous I might be doing clustering
so some of my top algorithms are k-means
k nearest neighbors spectral clustering
things like that if I have discrete if I
think that my data comes from these
discrete categories and if I think that
my data has continuous variations in the
outcome then I'll use something and I
know I'm calling this different names
every time I might call it
dimensionality reduction feature
extraction and pattern extraction here
I'm calling it embedding so I'm gonna
learn how to fit this data into some
continuous manifold so some smooth
manifold that defines how my data varies
with with the input input data and so
things like principal components
analysis autoencoders diffusion maps are
all embedding examples that learn kind
of a feature space or patterns that
describe that data now there's another
branch I think is important where you
might have partial labeled information
and that's that's a lot more subtle we
call these semi-supervised you can see
that it's kind of purple because it's
somewhere between supervised and
unsupervised maybe I only have partial
labels on some of the data or some of
the time and here I've added a new
decision box called model or modify if
all I want to do is kind of model this
system and understand and build
something that could kind of predict or
model that in the future then there's a
whole bunch of algorithms in the
generative models family so gans
generative adversarial networks are a
really popular neural network
architecture that is allowing you to
start generating new data that looks
like it came from this system very cool
and so this is actually called self
supervise because in some sense this has
two machine learning algorithms that
kind of are constantly fighting with
each other in this adversarial fashion -
one is kind of supervising the other and
it started off probably with some
partial labels from the true system
though now if I want to actually modify
my system through feedback control
if I have a robot that's actually in the
world doing stuff and it changes the
world this would be a branch called
reinforcement learning so this is where
you've probably heard of algorithms that
have beaten the human experts at go and
chess and they can play arcade games and
build you know now robots that go and
interact with the world
that's all reinforcement learning
there's some amount of labeled truth
data maybe the algorithm knows if it won
the game or lost the game but that
information is partial it doesn't know
if this intermediate move was a good
move or a bad move so that's another
example of semi-supervised learning and
there's fundamentally this feedback in a
lot of these systems there's feedback
signal to modify your system or some
control parameters and so this is not
exactly just a feed-forward flowchart in
the case of reinforcement learning and
similarly in supervised learning I can
make the same decision I might want to
modify my system and so I might want to
for example optimize certain parameters
of my system or develop a control law
and I might do that in a purely
supervised fashion as opposed to a semi
supervised fashion okay and again I
should really point out this is not
exhaustive this is not complete it's not
even a hundred percent you know accurate
this is just a good rough principled
sketch of how you can think about
different machine learning algorithms
based on kind of the aspects of what
information you have and whether or not
there's feedbacks back to your
environment here's another way of
looking at this I should point out that
this this figure is in a collaborative
paper machine learning for fluid
mechanics by myself barren Iraq and
Petros Kunitz aqus on the archive here
but this is just another way of looking
at that that same flowchart you have
kind of supervised Don one side
unsupervised on the other and
semi-supervised in the middle and you
can kind of categorize the various tasks
you might want to do in machine learning
and the different methods you have at
your disposal in these in these
categories okay so that's just an
overview of kind of this labeled
unlabeled discrete continuous breakdown
that a lot of us use to categorize
differ
machine learning methods and that's how
you kind of choose which method fits
fits your type of data and problem okay
thank you